hey perry i get so excited when i see
your name come up i'm like i feel like
we've grown up now together through this
saga and i get so excited when you give
me another season of this show because
it's so good peyton i'm starting with
you this time around because torrey's
evolution was one of my favorite
elements of this new season but it was
making me wonder were there any nerves
on your part about pulling that off
especially after everything tori did
through season three was there ever a
concern that you know there'd be no
realistic path to redemption for her
well first of all thank you um
you're one of the first people i'm
hearing feedback from so um
yes it was nerve-racking as hell like i
still really don't know you know hey i
was like is anyone gonna feel sympathy
for this chick like i've done a lot of
damage is there any coming back
you know i i feel like i have a very
complicated home life and family life
and you know that's kind of
shown a little bit more in the season
but and then also like my character's
relationship with amanda larusso was
really fun to to get to play
um
but yeah it was definitely definitely
nerve-wracking but i was really grateful
for the opportunity to have a little bit
more
job very well done i was very surprised
to see her teaming up with amanda in
that respect and it made all the sense
in the world
uh yeah they always surprised me i
wasn't expecting that at all
it was very very effective all right
tanner how did it feel filming that
final scene with billy because from the
viewer perspective it's like i can feel
the weight of the rage that robbie's
been carrying around all this time and
then i watch a scene like that and it's
this huge moment of catharsis for me so
while performing that scene is it the
perfect is it the pressure of doing an
emotional beat like that or can you feel
some of that catharsis too no i felt i
felt that i felt it from the second i
got the script um because it's what i've
been waiting for for
what and i feel like a lot of people
have been waiting for for
four years you know and um i when i
first got the script too like i was
reading it as reena i was like i don't
know where this is going
and then i got to it and i just started
reading it and just reading it i started
crying and i was like this is what i've
wanted for so long
um and then on the day it was just it
was so perfect it's just with an empty
dojo there
uh with billy and we were just so in it
there was like nobody on set it was just
me and him
and i feel like it was everything
building up to that for the past four
years which has been it was it was
really fun so no pressure whatsoever it
was just it was just fulfilling
i loved it so much beautiful moment i
feel bad asking you something like this
when i know you guys are already well
into the next season but just to tease
what's to come a little
can robbie reconcile with johnny and
still be a member of cobra kai or can
those two things just not exist at the
same time
i i
i think it's
hard because
koberkai is such in a place right now
that is uh
do i stare say evil
um
so it's kind of it's kind of hard to
find that balance
um
i i don't know
i i think i think anything's honestly i
truly do i think anything's a
possibility in this world
uh that that everything's in so i it
could be a possibility i think we got a
50 50 shot i don't know let's flip a
coin and find out
i can't wait for more all right mary i i
feel like i'm kind of giving you a
similar type of uh season five tease but
where is sam's hat head at at the very
end of the season because the last we
see of her she she kind of gets what she
wants to a degree daniel and johnny are
working together and they're also
supporting her even though she lost but
when she walks away she looks so
defeated to me after that last
conversation so
in your mind at the end of season four
is she in a position where she's just
completely lost all hope
i don't think it's lost all hope but i
think um
i think you know even more than than
wanting
it's like i feel like all of us
throughout like season four like we all
start from the place ending season three
and going into season four of like okay
like all questions will be answered by
this all valley and this this is the you
know this what we'll we'll get there but
it feels i don't know it's almost like
how it actually feels more filming where
it's like it felt far away like episode
10 we started episode one episode 10 the
idea of the all valley was like this big
concept that we all knew the whole
season was based on but it seemed like
years away it seemed like we had plenty
of time and then it just sped up on us
so it's like i almost feel like
samantha's like start her goal was like
yeah get you know daniel and johnny to
work together and that will be the
answer and then it's almost like that
that thing of like getting caught in the
trap and i've gotten i've done this in
my life so many times of of the wanting
and like if i want this thing once i get
that thing it will fix all my problems
if i you know i only want cake right now
or all i want is to to like you know if
my skin cleared up or if my you know me
you always think like if this thing
happens i will have all the answers and
i feel like in a way they finally get it
where yeah she gets the thing that she's
been working toward which was daniel and
johnny to like work together
but like the ultimate goal was beyond
that and it was
safety for safety for the valley the
soul of the valley having uh you know a
family and safety and belonging and all
these things that she hasn't had for so
long so i feel like she's not lost hope
because of it but it's almost like
finally taking a step back and seeing
what the bigger picture was all along
and it's like yes i got this small
victory but i
lost the war
that's why i love this show so much i
love the people i love the fun and the
entertainment value but it's that
complexity that leads you with something
to take with you well after the credits
roll they're gonna kick me out of here i
could talk to you guys forever
congratulations and next season in
person i want to see you guys face to
face i love it me too
that would be the dream all right all
the best guys see you soon
you